-Here's how the game works.
You're going to start --
Ryan, you will press the
start button on this buzzer
right here.
And then you'll draw a clue
from the top of this pile.
You have to get your teammate
to guess the clue
as quickly as possible.
Then hand the buzzer off to
the person on your right.
You can make any physical
gesture, say whatever you want.
You can't say the word
in the actual clue.
If you're holding the buzzer
when it goes off,
your team loses that round.
-Okay.
-We'll play three rounds.
[ Light laughter ]
Let's take our positions.
Here you go.
Ryan, you go there.
Andy, over there.
Tariq, all right.
Here we go, buddy.
-And I go to the right.
Woo! Okay.
-That's the first clue!
That's Ryan's clue.
-Oh, okay.
-Here we go.
[ Beeping ]
-This is a shirt that you wear
that is short and --
-Midriff. Tank top.
-Your girlfriend's shirt.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Go that way.
-Okay, sorry.
-Okay.
This is a drink that comes in
a gold glass -- gold cup.
[ Beeping intensifies ]
-Moscow Mule?
-Yes!
-What?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay, this is a move when
you want to assault someone --
[ Laughter ]
With this part of your body.
-Oh, it's a Full Nelson.
-You hit this part of their
body with this part
of your body.
-It's a head --
-The first part was right.
The second part wasn't.
-Head -- Head-Butt!
-Yes.
[ Beeping intensifies ]
-♪♪ Uh-oh ♪♪
-Spaghetti O'S!
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Robot, you're a robot.
-The dance.
-Okay, you're doing The Robot.
-Yeah, I am.
-That was The Robot?
-That was The Robot.
-That was your Robot?
[ Buzzer ]
[ Audience ohs ]
[ Fog horn ]
-Wait, that's not fair.
-Yes, it is!
It's totally fair.
-No, I got distracted
by his Robot.
Wait, that's not fair.
[ Band plays,
cheers and applause ]
-This is not the robot.
-Oldest trick in the book, baby.
We just got you with
the Robot Routine.
-Dude, but wait.
[ Laughter ]
How do you --
-That's The Robot?
-That was his slice --
-They're still talking about it.
-Andy, how do you do
The Robot?
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
All right, how do you do it?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How do you do The Robot?
Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, that move.
That shield's in your now!
[ Laughter ]
Thank you.
-Got a little John Candy
in there.
-Not bad.
-Okay, now who starts
this round?
-All right, you're up now.
So here we go,
question number six.
You already have the question
there, the clue.
-I have to do this?
-Yeah, you can do six.
-Okay.
-Just press the button.
[ Beeping ]
Dachshund are also called --
you know?
-Dogs?
-Yeah, what kind?
Like a hot, but --
-What?
Dachshund are called what?
-If you looked at it, it's like,
oh, there's one of those --
-Dalmatians?
-No, dude!
[ Light laughter ]
-A dog.
A dachshund is a little dog --
a Weiner Dog!
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay, okay, okay.
You probably have one of these.
You go to the gym, you do lots
of ab work and you get a --
-Six Pack.
-Yes.
[ Beeping intensifies ]
-She is a -- Kate Middleton's --
-Pippa!
-No, the mother-in-law!
-Oh, Camilla Parker Bowles.
-No.
-The mother-in-law?
-Her grandmother.
-The Queen!
-Yes, yes!
-Queen Elizabeth!
-You put money under your
pillow because she's gonna come,
or he's gonna come and give you
their money.
-Tooth fairy.
-Oh, man.
This is a -- right here.
[ Buzzer ]
-Soul Patch!
[ Fog horn ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, wait a minute!
Is that an actual thing
on a disc?
-Andy, what happened?
-What, what do you mean?
-You trashed it!
You trashed the place.
-This game is exhausting.
-You trashed the place!
-I know, I'm feeling it.
-I am shvitzing so much.
-No we didn't get it in time.
-Why?!
-No that's exactly --
These guys are the champs.
Give it up for Ryan Seacrest,
Tariq Trotter.
They're the champs.
[ Band plays,
cheers and applause ]
-We lose every time.
-Thank you, man.
-You guys --
[ Laughter ]
Congrats again.
My thanks to Ryan Seacrest,
Andy Cohen, Tariq Trotter!